if scientists experts government
officials feel that restaurants
and bars are the absolute worst
perpetrators of the spread of the
disease
then they should close us down and they
should
offer us some sort of financial
remuneration
to weather this period surviving the
pandemic has been a scramble for
independent restaurant owners like kevin
hickey
i never once considered closing i just i
never saw it as an option
all i kept thinking was pivot pivot
pivot how do i take our business
and change it between customers feeling
uncomfortable inside
and unpredictable capacity regulations
outdoor dining has become
a lifeline for many restaurants every
single person that calls to make a
reservation
says i want to be outside so we've got
24 seats inside that no one's interested
in sitting at
most of our staff isn't really
comfortable with indoor dining
so we're just doing our best to maximize
the back patio
and now restaurants like kevin's face
another
obstacle winter so how are owners that
rely on
outdoor dining going to survive the cold
weather months
my family's been in the neighborhood for
six generations
and i was struggling to find anything in
the
hot sexy downtown restaurant areas and
this
little corner tavern that i've known my
whole life was for sale
and i finally decided to buy it and open
a restaurant
on the street i grew up on after 20
years with the four seasons kevin
finally opened his
own bistro on the south side of chicago
in 2014.
it's called the duck inn named after his
grandmother's depression-era diner that
used to be blocks nearby
before lockdown kevin said business had
been going well
the michelin-rated chef had 35 employees
and his restaurant had become a
neighborhood staple
well right before the pandemic we really
were hitting
kind of our five-year stride the people
living around us
all the different neighborhoods really
started to get denser
with population and just see us as one
of the established restaurants and so we
were going into 2020
as highest we've been in five years
coronavirus quickly changed that
kevin says overall revenue has been down
50
since the pandemic hit the duck inn used
to seat nearly 200 diners between their
indoor and outdoor spaces
now they could host 44 people outdoors
only
and while kevin says delivery and
takeout is up a bit
it still only accounts for five to
fifteen percent of what they make on a
given night
it's been really really rough it's you
know the pandemic hit
we were shut down and we immediately
said okay we gotta find some revenue
so we put all of our wine and all of our
high-end whiskey
online and said you can come and buy all
this they bought it all in april kevin
received a loan from the federal
paycheck protection program
or ppp the loan was intended to provide
relief to small businesses in need
and the eight allowed kevin to cover two
months of payroll
i don't think that we would have been
able to survive without ppp
you know we were cutting everywhere we
could but once the ppp came
okay i can pay their salaries i can pay
health insurance
i can pay the rent i can pay the
utilities this makes a huge difference
that aid helped kevin survive until june
when chicago's reopening plan allowed
for outdoor dining as long as all tables
were at least six feet apart
in early july chicago allowed indoor
dining at 25
capacity no dining area in or out can
have more than 50 people
in late august the state announced new
regulations requiring customers at bars
and restaurants to keep their masks on
while interacting with staff with the
summer coming to an end
very soon we are extremely concerned
about how we're going to maintain
i'm on my third contractor trying to
build
an outdoor coverage but everyone says
they're
too busy we have an architectural
rendering for an outdoor covering that's
really awesome
we just don't have anybody that can
build it operating in colder weather
comes with added expenses
propane heaters cost hundreds of dollars
apiece and have been in high demand
tent rentals start climbing up into the
thousands and more formal enclosures
like this one
can get into the hundreds of thousands
of dollars depending on the features
but some owners and experts aren't
convinced these enclosures are worth the
expense
can you imagine with snow and winter
people saying oh i'd love to go eat in
that outdoor tent
i don't think these are realistic
scenarios saru jayaraman
leads food labor research at uc berkeley
she's concerned that any restaurant
dining indoor or
outdoor will not be safe during winter
prior to the pandemic we had done
years of studies funded by the national
institute of health
in which everybody in our industry
acknowledged
the restaurant industry is primarily
responsible for spreading the flu
if we're spreading the flu during flu
season what do you think is going to
happen with a pandemic that spread
through our breath then the government
is going to have to come in the same way
they would come into the airline
industry
same way they have come into the
automobile industry the financial
industry
and figure out how to maintain those
jobs those
people those incomes we as a society
and our elected officials need to
support those independent restaurants so
they can survive
congress should pass the restaurants act
and provide
support to independent restaurants so
that we don't end up with all chains
the bipartisan restaurants act was
introduced earlier in the summer
if passed it would create a 120 billion
dollar fund to help independent
restaurants
and the proposed bill would initially
target small businesses owned by women
veterans and people of color for now
kevin is working on new revenue streams
he's selling one of the most popular
menu items in select retail stores
and that may help keep him afloat but
he's still worried about the wider
industry
you shut down the restaurant industry
you shut down farmers
you shut down furniture makers talk to
the guy selling wine the guy selling
beer the guy making beer
the guy distilling tequila the china
glass silver companies that are making
plates i haven't bought a fork in six
months and i'm not going to buy
any of those things in 2020.